- Hey guys, it's Justine.
And today we are unboxing
the Traeger 885 Grill.
I am so excited about this.
I've actually been looking
into getting a grill.
And this one is perfect
because not only can you bake,
grill and smoke in it.
You can connect it to wifi
and control it with an app.
It's basically made for me!
A huge thank you to Traeger
for sponsoring this video
and sending us a grill to check out.
Jenna, the top of this says
that two people will
required for assembly.
- [Jenna] All right!
- All right, get those
assembly fingers ready.
This is a wood pellet grill.
And what makes this also different,
than a lot of normal
grills, is you can take it
down to a very low temperature.
But also take it all the
way up to 500 degrees
and you can control all
of this from your phone.
You can also control it on
the grill too, but come on.
If you can control it with
an app, why wouldn't you?
There's a safety feature
that won't let you turn it
on with the phone.
But you can control the
temperatures and turn it off.
So they have a variety
of different "flavors"
of wood pellets that you can get.
So the ones that we have here,
Signature, this is a maple
cherry and an artisanal hardwood.
And we've got a Hickory,
which is a natural flavored hardwood.
And on the back, it'll show you what type
of things these are recommended for.
So the Signature is pretty
much all across the board.
Good for basically cooking anything.
So the capacity on this
is, I can cook 10 chickens,
seven rib racks, and nine pork butts.
- [Jenna] We need more friends!
- We are.
Hello, (shouts) does
anybody want to come over
and have a pork butt?
Uh, they also sent me a hat.
Oh, that's actually nice
because the sun's in my eyes.
So they actually sent me three hats,
(laughs) which is great.
- [Jenna] I think the black looks nice.
- You think?
Time to unbox.
- [Jenna] There's a tag on your hat.
- Uh, yeah. This is fashion, Jenna.
(upbeat country music)
Look how nicely this is packaged!
There's also a little secret surprise.
This little box actually turns into
a little cardboard cabin house.
And our little niece
loves cardboard boxes.
So we're going to turn this
into a little cabin for her afterwards.
This is the first time I'm
not going to recycle this.
It's going to be recycled into a home.
Is this in the shot?
This box says start here.
So we're going to, we're going to do that.
Oh my gosh it's a note!
From the CEO of Traeger Grills!
Jeremy.
- [Jenna] Does everybody get that note?
- Yes.
"I just want to thank
you for choosing Traeger
and letting us into your backyard."
You're here.
You've infiltrated and I'm happy about it.
So here's our assembly guide.
They've given us all the
tools like I don't have to go
and hunt down some tools from my dad.
(packaging rustles)
They've even put little cup holders
for you to put your beverage of choice in.
This is it.
I like that it comes
pretty much put together.
You basically only have to
put the sides on and the legs.
And then you're off to the grilling races.
That's cool because Traeger
even has a YouTube channel
that they have a bunch of recipes on.
So I'm definitely going
to be checking that out
to get some grilling inspiration.
Oh my gosh.
There's more stuff inside of it.
Oh, (gasps) whoa!
Everything is very nicely packaged.
Um, is that English?
And the lever?
Oh, "Remove before use" okay.
whoa! It's just like a
never ending surprise.
It's cool cause this is
actually a convection grill too.
So it will be able to
circulate the air and the heat
to get a nice even cook.
And I love a good even cook.
I think this is the point where I need
to look at the directions.
It's that time now.
(upbeat guitar strumming)
And setup is starting now!
Should we high five before we start, or?
We did, we did.
We removed all the grill parts and stuff.
Okay. Here's the legs.
Let's flip this around and
lay it down and assemble.
(music continues)
I'd say we lift this up and
we tighten up the screws.
This is great, I'm so hungry.
The unfortunate reality
is I still need to go
to the grocery store
to get the foods that
I'm going to be grilling.
So I think grilling is actually
going to happen tomorrow.
There's someone coming down the driveway.
- Who?
- I'm unsure.
Do you think they want to help us?
- Is that our mom?
Oh it is.
- That's our mom!
- That's our mom, Mom's home!
So maybe she's going to
help us with the grill!
Go for it! Just go for it!
There's even wheels on this thing, look.
This is like all terrain.
So now, Jenna, we need to put this on.
I'm going to need your assistance.
It's in! Look at that!
- Woo!
- You guys can tell that the
sun has now shifted slightly.
We did a good job.
Well look, no, this needs
to go somewhere too.
This is our little side table.
Well, it looks like
everything is all set up.
I'm going to now sync this to the app
and do the rest of the setup process.
(smooth country music)
Okay. It's time to name the grill.
I've got it all connected.
"Sir-Ribs-A-Lot?
Stoked on Smoke.
Baby Got Brisket."
Shall I come up with a custom name?
- [Jenna] You can do custom?
- Yeah.
- [Jenna] What about iJust Grill?
- Oh, iJust Grill.
- (mumbles) (laughs)
Okay. We're going to do that.
All right.
"Welcome to the wood fried revolution,
for true grilling for,"
oh man, this is great.
Yeah, give me all the notifications.
Send me everything.
We have to season our grill.
"This is to be used on
the initial firing only."
We need to prime the auger.
It's priming.
Ignite.
Oh my gosh, it's igniting.
(grill hisses softly)
This is our first ignition.
We've got accessories.
Look at this!
Fancy, look how professional.
Goodness. We've got
Traeger barbecue sauces.
We've got a grill cleaner, all natural.
(surprised gasp) We need these.
Oh my goodness, look.
An internal temperature guide.
Magnetic tool hooks.
More barbecue sauce.
Pork and Poultry Rub.
Wow. This is so incredible.
- [Jenna] Oh my god!
- I smell it too.
- [Jenna] Smells good.
- Oh, it smells like a campfire.
Oh, it's starting to get warm.
It's happening.
Here's our grill cover.
Oh yeah.
We're up 82, 83 degrees.
(music continues)
It is the next day.
And we actually covered
the grill last night.
And good thing because
currently I'm in the East Coast
and there was a downpour.
So the grill is protected.
I have been inside preparing a feast.
I've got steaks, I've got chickens.
I've got cauliflower, broccoli, potatoes.
I think I got something else as well.
I'm also going to make chocolate
chip cookies for dessert.
There's a bunch of recipes
that I've kind of followed
but I've sort of mix
and matched some things.
And I'm gonna try to make all
of these things at the
same time on this grill.
There's so much space in this thing.
So that kind of gives
us a real opportunity
to make a bunch of different things.
At the same time.
I'm also can use this internal
temperature for the chicken.
Also gotta fill up my pellets.
(pellets rattle)
(music crescendos)
Just got a notification
from the Traeger app
that my grill is pre-heated.
Now we're going to put all
of this stuff on the grill
and I just want to be
completely honest with you guys.
I've never really done
much grilling in my life.
So I don't entirely, a hundred percent,
know everything about grilling.
So I'm not claiming to be an expert.
But what's great is, with the app,
I feel like it's giving
me all of the knowledge
that I need to know.
And you know what? You live and you learn.
So today, you guys are witnessing history.
(grill hisses)
Woo!
Toasty!
I've got some of the rub on this one.
And then on this guy,
I've got another one
of the barbecue sauces.
So this chicken, I have a nice little
Italian seasoning marinade
that my mom actually made.
So this is, uh, this one's for my mom.
Got the chicken marinading
in some of the Traeger barbecue sauce.
These are some potatoes with
a little garlic seasoning
and some random butter that I found
in the fridge that looked kind of good.
So I threw it on there.
This is a Parmesan Broccoli
Cauliflower recipe that I found
on the Traeger recipes.
I also threw some garlic
in there because why not?
Oh my gosh our kabobs
too, I got so much food.
Good luck, little buddies.
Now we wait.
(tense music)
I just got a notification that my chicken
has reached the internal
temperature of 165.
Grill probe 166.
I was aiming for 165.
So guess what guys, I'm going
to take a little peek at it.
Look at this.
Look at those little grill marks!
I think I should've put it this way.
I feel like that's what
you're supposed to.
I put it the wrong way.
I just learned something.
And so did you guys.
You guys aren't done yet either.
Everything is still cooking.
I'm gonna give the chicken
a few more minutes,
just cause I like mine kind
of done a little extra.
And then we'll take them out.
And then we'll kind of
monitor everything else
that's happening in here.
And then we eat!
The chicken is ready.
- [Jenna] It's probe-ably done.
- It's, oh my gosh, ha!
"It's probe-ably done."
This looks delicious.
Okay. I'm going to put
this into this chicken.
They get that temp.
(probe beeps)
Chicky.
Okay, these are marinated ones.
I think these actually might be ready.
- [Jenna] It's hot!
- Oh my God, it's incredible.
Oh, is that good!
I think we're, like,
fricking ready, actually.
We're set.
(grill hisses)
I got a whole meal right here.
Our potatoes are needing
a little extra care.
- [Jenna] Those look good.
- Yeah, those are pretty much good to go.
Look at that.
- [Jenna] It's very nice.
- I know, presentation is everything.
My feast is complete.
Now it's time for a taste test.
Complete is a lie, because the
potatoes are still cooking,
but we can get to those after.
Broccoli taste test.
(muffled) Well, I like how these little,
I shouldn't talk with my mouth full.
(garbled) This is a taste test, for real.
The broccoli was incredible.
Let's taste this chicken.
So this, I used the Traeger
barbecue sauce on it.
Oh, that's good!
It has like a little hint of sweetness.
Okay the steak. I also used the rub
and the Traeger barbecue sauce on here.
Oh, that's good.
I can't believe is the first
time I've ever grilled.
I'm pretty impressed
with the outcome, Jen.
- [Jenna] Looks good.
- Maddie is also excited.
I'm gonna get a little of this vegetable
to see how that cooked.
Mm, this is good.
I put a little butter,
pepper, and sea salt flakes
on the kabobs.
I've been looking forward
to this since yesterday
when we un-boxed the thing.
We're going to get a small
taste of mommy's meal, okay?
You ready? Lay down.
All the way down, all the way down.
Good boy.
Is that Maddie approved?
The sun is going down.
So we might be making some
nighttime chocolate chip cookies.
But we have to test out
the baking in this thing.
Super hyped about that.
I'm going to finish my meal,
then get ready for dessert.
Mm, so good.
I forgot about the potatoes!
I was prepping my cookies,
before the sun sets!
- Whoa!
- Oh, those look good!
Look how nice this one is.
Get over there.
These actually look so good.
We gotta get this to 350 degrees.
I should've just left
them on the baking sheet,
but I, uh, I didn't because I got nervous.
You can actually go into the cookie recipe
and hit "Make" and it'll set the timer
and do everything, basically, for me.
There it goes, "Begin Cook."
It's happening.
They're already cooking!
Oh boy.
Let's go have some potatoes
and wait for our cookies.
Oh, I'm hyped!
Sun is going down.
The moon is coming up
and long ago somebody has
left with the cup.
Checking on the cookies.
Oh wow!
They're actually looking really good.
I need to go get some sea
salt to add to the top
for a little extra flavor bang.
Oh my God, these look incredible.
Whoa.
Some sea salt flakes.
(shaker rattles)
(sniffs)
We'll let them cool off for a second.
(smooth rhythmic music)
And the taste test.
(cookie crunches)
I mean, I've never had
a chocolate chip cookie
that was made on a grill.
It's interesting cause it has like slight
little, like, smokey taste to it.
But it tastes so awesome
with these salt flakes.
Oh, my goodness Jenna.
- [Jenna] Oh yeah. I'll get in on that.
- Get in on that.
A huge thank you to Traeger
for sponsoring this video.
They have some incredible
videos on their YouTube channel.
I'll put a link in the description.
If you want to check that out.
And also a link to the grill that I have.
If you guys want to check that out
and all of the incredible accessories
that they have to go with it.
I'm going to finish up this cookie.
And we'll see you guys in the next video.
Peace.
Here Jen, which one do you want?
- [Jenna] Oh, I'll pick one.
- Okay. There you go.
- [Man] Good job guys.
- Thanks dad.
(smooth rhythmic music)